>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Guy Lamolinara:
It is now pleasure
to introduce our distinguished
authors.
To my right is Victor
Hazan, who is an authority
on Italian food and wine.
He is a life-long collaborator of
Marcella Hazan, who is the queen
of Italian cuisine in America.
She unfortunately passed away
in 2013, but her spirit and,
of course her recipes and ideas
about Italian food
will live forever on.
It was Marcella Hazan, together
with Victor who brought us
"The Classic Italian Cookbook",
a book that introduced Americans
to classic Italian cuisine.
Whenever you have a dish
of classic Italian food
such as spaghetti bolognese or
veal saltimbocca you have Marcella
and Victor Hazan to thank for their
dedication to educating Americans
on what real Italian food is and
about using authentic products.
Today he will discuss his
and Marcella's new book
called, "Ingrediente".
And to my left is our other
author Alessandro Frassica,
who is the author of
"Veggie Panino".
Like Victor's book,
"Veggie Panino" focuses
on the importance of
good ingredients.
As both of these authors
would agree,
all ingredients are
not created equal.
Your finished product
can only be as good
as the ingredients
that went into it.
By the way we call in American
an Italian sandwich a panini,
but in Italy panini
is actually a plural.
The singular is a panino and, thus,
the books title, "Veggie Panino."
Please join me in welcoming Victor
Hazan and Alessandro Frassica.
[ Applause ]
Victor I understand you have a
short film about Marcella Hazan.
>> Victor Hazan: Yes.
It is a short film taken
when Marcella was given the
Lifetime Achievement Award presented
by the James Beard Foundation.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Okay.
>> Victor Hazan: And Marcella picked
up probably every single
award available-
>> Guy Lamolinara: Right.
>> Victor Hazan: In
food in her lifetime.
And if we have a couple
of minutes do you-
>> Guy Lamolinara: Yes.
>> Victor Hazan: Think we could.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Could
we see that please?
>> Victor Hazan: Yeah,
is that the one.
[ Inaudible background discussion ]
>> Guy Lamolinara: "Master classes."
>> Victor Hazan: I'm sorry.
>> Guy Lamolinara:
There are two films.
One's called "Master
Classes", is that the one?
>> Victor Hazan: It could be.
>> Guy Lamolinara: It could be.
>> Victor Hazan: Master.
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Why don't you start it
and we'll see if it's
the correct one.
Start the "Master Classes."
Let's see.
[ Silence ]
Is this the right one?
>> Victor Hazan: It looks,
it looks like it, yeah.
[ Music ]
There is no sound with it?
>> Guy Lamolinara: Is there sound?
>> Julia Child always called
her her "Italian Counterpart."
And years back Americans didn't
know about northern Italian cooking.
And this woman Marcella is
instrumental in teaching Americans
about norther Italian cooking.
And she's such a kick,
let me tell you.
>> We're going to ask why the
world's most accomplished chefs
to work with her magic on
the most basic kind of meal.
She is the remarkable Marcella
Hazan and welcome to you.
>> Thank you.
>> And she is known as
Italy's national treasure.
Even our friend, the
great Julia Child,
considers her a mentor
in all things Italian.
For more than 25 years she's
been teaching Americans
about Italian cooking.
You probably didn't know about pesto
until Marcella told you about it.
>> Italian cuisine is a
favorite in this country.
And its popularity is due
in part to Marcella Hazan
who is a cookbook author and many
times she is called the godmother
of Italian cooking in America.
And here is the queen of
Italian cooking Marcella Hazan,
who has produced this
book "Essentials
of Classic Italian Cooking."
>> Marcella, your first book
was a revelation for me.
It was the first time I saw
in print the kind of food
that I was raised with,
with my Italian family.
But the thing that I think I will
be eternally grateful to you for was
when I came to study
with you in Bologna
in the mid 70's you introduced
me to what was to become one
of the great loves of my life,
the region of Emilia-Romagna.
As you know, it is the main
love of my life professionally.
Of course, my Tuscan family
still doesn't understand this.
Well, Marcella, thank you and thank
you for all you've given all of us.
>> Okay. I was not the
one to make you happy now.
>> A little more, yes.
You're with me now Marcella.
>> Okay.
>> You didn't set out to
be a famous cook, right?
I mean, you're a biochemist.
You have two doctorates.
>> Yes, I am.
>> Yeah.
>> But I use it.
I'm crazy almost like this.
>> This dish is called.
>> Pesce all'acqua pazza.
>> And in English that
translates to.
>> Fish with crazy water.
>> Fish in crazy water.
>> Yeah. Brian, this is a good
example of Italian cooking,
because we have a way
of saying in Italy
that has the same importance
what you keep out of them
and what you put into them.
And here actually you put salt
and pepper and lemon, that's it.
>> That's it.
>> Marcella arrived on
the scene like a comet
and nothing was the same again.
The food that we thought
of as Italian turned
out to be more American
than Italian.
For many of us, Marcella was
the beginning of the real thing.
La Vera Cucina, "The True Cuisine."
Thank you Marcella.
When we think of pesto,
we think of you, Marcella.
Thank you.
And when we think of pork simmering
in milk, a dish so succulent
that one only has to think
about it to taste it.
We thank you.
And when we think of Vinicia,
the place that you gave
so many cooking classes to so many
people, we thank you, Marcella.
>> There are so many
different Italian items
that you introduced to
this country, right.
>> Yes.
>> She's very modest.
>> Extra virgin olive oil.
>> Yeah, the extra
virgin, balsamic vinegar.
>> Well, unfortunate, because
now they use it for everything.
>> We're drinking it like wine now.
>> Marcella is particularly gifted.
She's uncalculating, unpremeditated.
She, she cooks as she breathes,
you know, as she walks.
It has become a reflective
act on her part.
She, she is part to a ingredient,
to its color, to its shape,
to its freshness or
lack of it, to its bulk.
And out of her [inaudible]
comes, comes a dish.
And it is, she is true
to herself in this.
Marcella is always true to herself.
[ Music ]
>> Guy Lamolinara: Thank you.
That really gave us a
great picture of Marcella
and the great influence
she had on Italian food.
And Alessandro, I understand
you have a slide,
film that you'd like to show us.
Can you tell us about it?
>> Alessandro Frassica: Right.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Can
you run that please?
Or do you want to introduce
it first?
>> In the slide part, first
thing, thank you to be here.
It's a big pleasure to me to
come from Italy and to be here
to present my book, myself.
Sorry for my English.
It's not so-
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Your English is fine.
>> Alessandro Frassica: Perfect.
But yeah, this is my
[inaudible] in Florence.
It's a place where
we make only panini,
because in this word panino
there are, this is our menu
and there are many things
to say and I am happy
to be here to, to explain something.
[ Silence ]
>> Ingredient, ingredient is the
word, the word that today we talk
because for me, this is my
first one, book, "il Pan'ino."
And I am happy that with the panino,
with the [inaudible] we have here
in Washington to talk about this.
This is the second
one, Panino Veggie.
It's only evolution of what we
do because for me it's important
to talk about the food
with or without meat,
fish, now we talk about this.
It's for me great opportunity
to explain this.
I was saying that ingredients
it's very important,
because for me everything
starts from the ingredient.
The quality of the ingredients, it's
the first thing important thing.
The panino for me is the, the tool,
the container where I can
do what I want to explain.
This is my philosophy.
And here you can see some pictures
of the book, different recipes.
Because I think that they, they
get word it's so interesting.
When we think of panino we think
always of salami, prosciutto,
mozzarella, picolino cheese.
But this is very important,
but it's very important even
to explain how there is a
word, a [inaudible] word,
and even the panino can be a way
to taste, to understand this word.
Not only for who is vegetarian,
but even for everybody
because it's very important
to understand what there
is behind these words.
In this book my recipes,
but even different recipes
of friends, famous chef in Italy.
And each of them have done
one recipe for my book
and it's a great honor for
me, for me to have this.
Okay.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Thank you.
Tell us about a panino and
what makes it different
from just an ordinary sandwich.
>> Alessandro Frassica:
First thing that when we talk
about panino we have to
talk about the bread.
Because usually when I see,
even in Italy, not only outside,
we never talk about the bread.
We always talk about what we put
inside but we forget the first thing
that for me is the
first important thing.
In the book there is,
I want to talk about,
about flour because it's
very, very important
to say what is or meal
or other things.
I don't want to do too
difficult to explain.
But there are some simple things
that is very important to know.
And after, if you want
to develop this
but everything starts from here.
This is very, very important
not only for the taste okay,
but even for the healthy,
because we cannot think
when we eat something it's
only for tasting flavor,
but even to stay well,
to stay better.
Panino is important but even the
way with which you to, to mix,
to combine this ingredients.
For me a panino is very, very
important harmony, the balance.
I see that many people that more
things you put the panino is better.
Many people can't,
especially sorry, from USA,
and they tell me put prosciutto,
mozzarella and you have this icons
and pesto, mozzarella, prosciutto
and they want to put everything,
because they think that more
things they put, this is better.
It's not, no.
Simplicity is the really truth.
Simplicity to do this you must have
with quality of the ingredients.
And how to combining them and always
I look forward to find harmony
and balance when you have to feel,
to taste the different ingredients,
but they together are
something more.
I always say you know one, one
must two, not 1.50, always and then
to have something is
to became it better.
This is the difference for me
from a panino and a sandwich.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Okay.
Thank you.
Victor you have a chapter
in your book
where Marcella writes how I
fell in love with ingredients.
Can you tell us about that?
>> Victor Hazan: Yeah.
This was Marcella's
introduction to, to her book,
the book that representing
today is called, "Ingrediente",
which is Italian for ingredients.
And too this was Marcella's
summation,
the last work of her life,
for her last years into.
And too much of the
essence of cooking,
the whole purpose of
cooking is taste.
And taste depends on getting to
the essence of the ingredient,
the essential quality
of the ingredient.
And as Alessandro was saying
the more ingredients you put
into something, the more
muddled the taste becomes.
And Marcella fell in love in a
sense with the central character
of the material that
she was working with.
If she was working with artichokes,
you know, she would prepare a dish
and put, the star was the artichoke.
You tasted the artichoke.
There weren't four or five
other things along with it.
And to Marcella cooking to taste
not of the person who produced it,
but of the material that was on
the plate, as simple as possible.
And Marcella became
celebrated for producing recipes
with only two or three ingredients.
She has a tomato sauce with only
three ingredients that's become one
of the most widely used
tomato sauces in the world.
And the interesting thing that
I saw, I saw an article in the
"Wall Street Journal",
not too long ago.
And it said that industrial food
companies have hit on a new thing.
Food with very few ingredients,
with no more than two
or three ingredients.
And I said, "Well, if only
Marcella were around."
Really because she would enjoy it.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Yeah, she
would set them straight, I'm sure.
Okay. I, there's one place in your
book where you talk about a woman
who talked about pasta and
she said I only used fresh.
>> Victor Hazan: Oh, I
remember the incident very well.
And this happened not
infrequently in Marcella's preps.
This was on a book tour and
it was the local food editor
of a city in the north.
And the first thing she said
after greeting Marcella, said,
Marcella I want you to know that
the only pasta I ever use is
fresh pasta.
And, of course, she meant pasta
that she made herself at home.
And Marcella said, oh you poor girl.
You don't know what you're missing.
Because you know to us, yes,
fresh pasta we are from Romagna.
We spent much of our
life in Bologna.
We loved [inaudible],
tortellini, lasagna,
but there is so much
else that is different.
The pasta you buy in the stores,
penne, rigatoni, spaghetti,
spaghettini, they have a, a
character or quality they marry
with sauces in a way
that fresh pasta doesn't.
So, if you eliminate all of
that you're eliminating, like,
80% of the flavors that
Italian pastas can deliver.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Okay.
Alessandro, I was looking at
some of the recipes in your book
and I couldn't believe some
of things you were using,
like brussel sprouts
like in a panino.
How do you get your inspiration
for doing things like that?
In fact, I see that
on your cover there.
>> Alessandro Frassica: It's
very easy because I said before,
for me a panino is like
a plate, is a recipe.
I learned many things with my
friend's chef that when they come
to find me they told me when
you do one panino do exactly
like we do when we think a plate.
And then the balance like I said
before with the salty, bitter,
the different flavor, no.
And then the inspiration is
when even I go in a restaurant,
when I go to find a producer,
I think with this ingredient what
can be the intelligent combination
to do this.
And our menu is always
traditionally,
because the tradition is
a treasure that we have
that we cannot forget this.
But I think that we must
be even contemporary,
because the world is changing.
Our way of life is changing.
For example, in Italy now we use
as before to come back home to it,
we say, with the legs
under the table, you know.
No, no, even we stay out.
We go to eat, but even if
I don't come back home,
if I don't have my wife or
my mother that cook for me,
now this is only what we call
it, we don't do this anymore.
But I have to find
something good, healthy.
And even if it is fast the time,
the quickly, and then I have
to think something of good, of
healthy, quick, contemporary.
This is for me the word
of what, what I do.
And then tradition, but to think
what are the, our way of life
of today and we don't have
to forget the quality,
the taste and the healthy.
>> Guy Lamolinara: You
have a recipe in your book
for what's called a hamburgerino,
but yet it's a vegetarian panino.
What is that?
>> Alessandro Frassica: It's a, it's
a game because in Italy we use it
to do a Miranda, is like,
I like to call it Miranda
because [inaudible] is not
the same things in our mind.
And Miranda, panino con la frittata,
panino con la frittata put on plate,
but even when you are a child
and all your mother gave you
these you know when you go
for [inaudible] the school, no.
Give you panino con la frittata and
[inaudible] and this I have done.
This contemporary veggie and
then I have done this game.
Use one omelette but to a disc no,
like if it was in a [inaudible]
to put some in this recipe
you put some kale inside.
And there is like an omelette,
the bread, the tomato, the cheese.
I use picolino cheese, usually a
sheep cheese that we have Tuscany.
And I add my own ketchup
with a good tomato
and a good red pepper
[inaudible] and some salad in this.
So it is a game like if
it was a really hamburger.
And then it's a way to explain, like
even with a joke you can do quality.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Thank you.
Victor, your book has all
these various chapters
about different ingredients
and one, of course,
is on parmigiano-reggiano.
How is that different from that
stuff you buy in the green can?
>> Victor Hazan: Oh, the difference
again is in the raw material.
And the raw material that goes into
parmigiano-reggiano is a product
of a specific environment and
of the reaction of milk produced
by cows to that environment.
Milk is one of the most
sensitive products in the world.
When there was the
explosion in Chernobyl
and there was a fall-out all
over Europe and food stuff began
to taken off the market because of
the exposure to possible fall-out.
The first product in Italy to be
taken off the market was fresh milk.
And I say this to indicate
how sensitive it is
to the place where it is produced.
So the milk for parmigiana-reggiano
is limited
to a few provinces
in northern Italy.
Part of them in them in
the province of Bologna
but mostly the provinces
of Parma and Modena.
It is also a procedure
that is 800 years old
and hasn't been changed except
for the source of heat that heats
up the milk in the, in the kettles.
Originally the heat would
have been fire, firewood.
Today the heat is better
controlled; it's gas.
But otherwise the milk produce,
is created exactly the same way.
There, part of the milk come
from the evening milk and part
of milk come from the morning skim.
It is cooked in these large kettles.
Each kettle produces exactly as much
cheese necessary to make two wheels.
And then those wheels are subjected
to salting, to brine, to aging.
And only after three years may
be called parmigiana-reggiano.
So it's a little bit different
than the stuff you buy in the can.
>> Yes, it's quite different.
>> Yeah.
>> Guy Lamolinara: One
of the things, of course,
that Marcella wanted to do
in America is educate
us on Italian cuisine.
How far do you think
we've come in the process?
>> Victor Hazan: Well,
I think as far as access
to ingredients the
change has been enormous.
Because when Marcella first
started cooking in this country
when we were married and came
over, there was virtually nothing.
And through her books, through
the respect and curiosity
that she aroused in people
about Italian cooking I think we've
come today to virtually everything
that is available to
Italians in Italy.
Almost everything is
available someplace,
somewhere in this, in this country.
The only thing I must say
that is still lacking the
quality of agriculture.
In Italy we have vegetables
that have extraordinary flavor.
I find it difficult in America to
get that flavor in the vegetable.
The vegetables are either overgrown,
overwatered, they may be beautiful
but they don't have that
intensity or flavor,
that quality that made
Marcella fall in love-
>> Guy Lamolinara: Right.
>> Victor Hana: With
ingredients in the first place.
>> Guy Lamolinara: How about you
Alessandro have you tried making any
of your paninos in the
United States and what kind
of success have you had with that?
>> Alessandro Frassica: No, no,
but even here you can
find good ingredients.
I think that when I do something
here many immigrants come
from Italy, okay.
But if you can find something of
good here for me is even interesting
to use is what you
can find in the place.
Because for me my philosophy is
even what my parents told me,
when you come back home
you open this [inaudible]
and you always find
something, always.
And if you're creativity and the,
your what you feel to do together,
you always find something.
That to say, here in USA if you
want you can do a great quality
of panino if you want.
>> Guy Lamolinara: What about
the bread that we have here?
>> Alessandro Frassica: In USA the
bread are, there are good flour.
I have tasted many
good things and I,
I think that we can do very
good things if we want.
The problem is very often
people doesn't want to do.
We see the cost, you know.
It's normal that some
products cost much more.
For example, we talk
parmigiana-reggiano, to do one kilo
of parmigiana-reggiano you need 15
liters of milk, one kilo, 15 liters.
Parmigiana-reggiano need, when
you to have 24 months of aged
and even more, but you need to
have a product that stay 24 months
in your warehouse it have a cost.
Then what I tell you is
it's okay to see the price.
But it's, you have to
one question to yourself,
more if one thinks cost too less.
Because you have to do
this kind of why it cost?
So it's so cheap, not only
when it is so expensive,
because this is the question
that is important to do ourself.
>> Guy Lamolinara: What do you think
about Italian restaurants
here in this country?
>> Victor Hazan: That
was not on the program?
[laughter]
>> Guy Lamolinara: Okay
you better not answer that.
But why don't we take some
questions form the audience?
Who has a question?
Please go up to the
microphone, please.
>> Hi. My name is Carlotta and
I have the privilege of being
from the same hometown of Marcella
that is Cesenatico on
the Adriatic Coast.
So as such I love Italian
food and food from Romagna.
So I have a question for Victor.
I have tried multiple times to make
pidadina, but I'm not quite able
to replicate the piadina.
I can [inaudible] that
I can make in Italy.
So I'm really, really curious
to know whether Marcella was
really able to make piadina
and whether it was the same
that she would in Cesenatico.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Did you get that?
>> Victor Hazan: Oh, yeah.
>> Guy Lamolinara: I'm sorry I
didn't hear what food you said.
>> Piadina.
>> Victor Hazan: Piadina.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Piadina.
She's asking if you could make,
if Marcella made piadina
here in the US?
>> Victor Hazan: Marcella
made piadina.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Maybe we
should tell people what that is.
>> Victor Hazan: Piadina
is a, is a flat bread.
It's an unleavened bread and
in Romagna it's flattened out
and it used to be cooked
on an earthenware.
We called it a testo,
an earthenware disc
that was put directly over fire.
And it was slightly charred.
It came off the testo and it
was slightly charred, very thin.
And we would either eat with a
little bit of, cut into, into wedges
and make panini out of it.
There was prosciutto, mozzarella,
but other panini we made was
with grains, wild grains a
little bit that were wild grains
that were sauteed with
garlic and olive oil.
You'd put it on the piadina
and that made it wonderful,
a wonderful panino.
I, Marcella made piadina at home.
I must, however, that in our many
returns to Cesenatico the quality
of the piadina there
has sadly declined.
It's no longer rolled out
with a rolling pin by hand,
but it is rolled out
through big steel rollers.
It is cooked on a steel griddle
and somehow the composition
of it doesn't have that flavor and
that, that crackly texture it used
to have and that Marcella
could get at home.
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Anyone else a question?
>> Victor Hazan: If you have the
time Guy, I don't know if you do.
But other video-
>> Guy Lamolinara: Let's
watch the other video.
>> Victor Hazan: That's very
interesting because you see,
it's about Marcella and
her last two weeks of life.
Of course, she didn't know
they were her last two weeks.
The "New York Times" had sent
an interviewer to Longboat Key,
where we lived to interview
her and to ask
if she would produce some dishes for
the "Times" and this was videotaped.
And this was the public view
that anybody had of Marcella.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Oh.
>> Victor Hazan: And it
is quite moving, I think.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Okay,
could you show that, please?
[ Music ]
>> The sauce for the first
course is a very easy one.
Onion, butter, and tomato, that's
altogether at the same time.
>> You don't cook the onion first.
[ Music ]
>> Not many spice because
I got tired about listening
that people think that the
Italian food is full of spice.
They come here and
they look at my kitchen
and they say, where are your spice?
One is here.
The other is there.
So. In a few months I will be 90.
That's too much.
[ Music ]
>> I think the reason that
Italians are the happiest.
[ Music ]
>> Want me to do that?
[ Food cooking ]
>> [Inaudible] because this
part cook faster than this now.
>> Right.
>> So I have to do this.
>> It's very smart.
>> I wish I had thought of that.
>> You didn't.
>> No, sorry.
>> Oh, look at this relish.
[ Music ]
When I married Victor I
never cook in my life.
But we had one thing that
was much more production.
When I did try anything and
it came right, he was jumping
from his chair and come to kiss me.
I want to be so happy.
Well, I'm glad that you like that.
>> It's fantastic.
>> It was very easy to be done.
>> Yes it was.
[ Music ]
>> That was great.
Thank you for bringing that.
[ Applause ]
Anyone else have some questions?
>> Yeah, I'm Bernie.
Over in the Mediterranean
and in general I know noticed
that fennel grows like
wild, like weeds everywhere.
But when you want to get fennel
to put in your ingredients to put
in your dishes here in the US
it's like out of sight cost wise.
>> Guy Lamolinara: And the
question is, I'm sorry.
>> Oh, for Victor is what he feels
about fennel as an ingredient.
>> Guy Lamolinara: What
do you think about fennel
as an ingredient in
the United States?
>> Victor Hazan: Well, as a
vegetable it's perfectly acceptable.
We can get very good
fennel [inaudible].
Marcella talks about it in
the book, "Ingrediente."
But if you're talking about fennel,
wild fennel [inaudible]
there are very many varieties
of wild fennel available in Italy.
But they're also available here,
except they don't come to the market
and in Italy you can go
to the produce market
and there may be an old lady with
just a few things in the store.
But she will have some
wild, some wild arugula
and maybe some wild fennel and
that has a different purpose.
That has, that is for flavoring.
Fennel the kind you buy in
the market here is a vegetable
that you can eat either
raw, or fried, or braised,
or baked, and it's excellent.
It's a wonderful vegetable.
>> Do you use fennel
in any of your panino?
>> Alessandro Frassica: There
is on recipe there is fennel,
because there is a typical Sicilian
recipe, the orange with fennel, no.
And then I have done one panino
using what I said before,
the tradition but contemporary.
>> I get it.
>> Alessandro Frassica: And
then fennel is a nice ingredient
and fennel seeds is, are inside one
of the most famous
[inaudible] salami
that we have is fennel
[inaudible] like a salami,
but inside there are fennel seeds.
And this flavor is
very, very interesting.
>> Victor Hazan: May I
add something to that,
because Alessandro reminded me.
One of the things that we find very
peculiar is that Italian sausages
in this country by default,
Italian sausage contains
fennel seeds in America.
And Italy we have places that
have sausages with seeds.
But you go to Venice or Bologna or
Piedmont or anywhere in the north
of Italy and you have these
marvelous sausages, wonderful pork.
There is no fennel in them.
They all they taste of is
meat and it's very peculiar.
Have you ever found a simple Italian
pork sausage in the United States
that did not contain fennel seeds?
>> Guy Lamolinara: No.
>> Victor Hazan: It's frustrating.
>> Alessandro Frassica:
So the problem is
that when I can you say another
country I see some recipe
ingredients that we
don't use in Italy.
I say if I have to say one
recommendation, the first thing is
to look for the authenticity because
many, many things that are here,
many restaurants, many places sell,
like, Italian and not Italian,
but we don't eat this
[inaudible] and then it's better
to know less things,
but true things.
This is what I recommend.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Who else
would like to ask a question?
>> I wanted to thank Victor
for all of the cookbooks
that you and your wife did.
They were very welcomed
by me and my family.
>> Guy Lamolinara:
She said thank you
for all the books you've written.
>> And I have enjoyed
your son's books
as well, Juliana, his cook books.
And Alessandro, I personally
prefer pecorino too and I wondered
if you could discuss
your preference for that.
>> Alessandro Frassica:
The question.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Do you have
a preference for pecorino?
>> Well, you, he said
that he did over-
>> Guy Lamolinara: Not that you did.
>> Alessandro Frassica: I
come from Florence, Tuscany.
And the cheeses that in Tuscany
you produce are always sheep cheese
because the tradition is that
many a story from [inaudible] came
to Tuscany and the, we have sheep.
It's difficult to find
cow, goat cheese.
And pecorino is a simple one.
I like so much the fresh one,
the marzolino, for example.
But even if it's a
little bit more aged,
because in this word
there is a world.
Sorry, for the mistake on words.
And yes, I love pecolino
cheese, yes.
>> Thank you.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Thank you.
I'm really enjoying this.
I had a question because my
relatives are from the southern part
of Italy and they use some
spinach and things like that.
Is that common up north to put
that kind of ingredient into a meal
and they combine, like, spinach with
raisins in a dish that I know of.
So I'm just curious.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Do you
know of any Italian dishes
that combine raisins with spinach?
She's from the southern, her
family's from the southern part
of Italy and that's
something they do down there.
So you know of that?
>> Victor Hazan: The kind of
dishes that combine spinach.
>> Yeah.
>> Guy Lamolinara: With raisins.
>> Victor Hazan: With raisins.
Well, not spinach with
raisins, but raisins are used
in the cooking of Venice.
And we use raisins and onions
and a dish uses sardines and used
to preserve the sardines.
It was made originally
for those Venetians
who were traveling
very far away on boats
and they would take local
homemade food with them.
And one of the dishes
was sardines fried
in vinegar and onion and raisins.
And they, they lasted
for a very long time.
But raisins with vegetables
I don't know Alessandro.
I, if in Tuscany you serve raisins
with vegetables like spinach.
>> Alessandro Frassica:
[inaudible] in Italian.
Okay right understood, yeah.
In Sicily there is one
recipe here in one place
where we use moscato raisin.
It's very sweet and usually
a typical combination is the
scarolla [phonetic].
>> Guy Lamolinara: Escargot.
>> Alessandro Frassica: It is a
little bit bitter with the raisin
because a little bit sweet and
even anchovies because it's salted.
What I said before, no the
different kinds of flavor
but together gave you
harmony and balance.
And then I have used in the
book one without anchovies
because it's veggie, but I
have said this in the recipe
that usually scamorza cheese,
it's cow cheese with scarolla
with the raisin and
anchovies if you want to
and the veggie version without it.
It's very interesting.
In south Italy we use braising
[inaudible] we say, no.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Sweet and sour.
Anyone else.
Well, please thank our guests Victor
Hazan and Alessandro Frassica.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.